you're manipulating these equations and
then you come up with something which
you know is a question in number Theory
it's a question of you know how many
prime numbers at a certain level or
something like that
[Music]
is the relationship between mathematics
and reality and Peter come back to you
because another way of stating it is is
mathematics something that we discover
or that we invent in other words were
prime numbers in the universe before we
thought of them yeah so this is a kind
of a standard philosophical question
about mathematics and I think most
mathematicians take more of the the idea
the kind of platonistic idea that this
is a discovered this is not invented
it's discovered and it's probably just
the experience you have
um learning some new kind of mathematics
or finding something it's
mathematical ideas at least really good
ones often are not they're not really
they're they're not at all obvious they
all it takes it they're not natural
things for your brain to understand the
kind of abstraction and ways of thinking
that are needed to
to get into some deep ideas and
Mathematics really understand them are
actually very unnatural things so
they're
yeah the psychological experience is
certainly one of discovery that you're
discovering something which really had
nothing at all to do with the way your
mind normally works or the way human
beings
you know behave and perceive the
universe but but it was it's there
anyway and and once you see it you know
it um there's a recognition that oh wow
this actually it is explains all sorts
of things but Marika does it
does that mean that when we think about
what the universe is made of that in in
addition to the sort of the stuff that
we whiz around it in circles in CERN
that numbers somehow existed I mean it's
a difficult to imagine that they exist
somewhere
so again I think that actually Bears to
Peter's point that some of these things
are quite abstract and outs out of sort
of you know everyday sort of experience
right so so we know that um you know
certain patterns in sort of numbers seem
to play you know fundamental roles in in
in in physics you know they determine
sort of properties of of physical
particles and you know that it's this
interwoven nature right that somehow you
know you you you went from your
observations of how your physical
particles you know behave you develop
your theories from this your theories
are sort of written in the language of
mathematics that you knew you borrowed
sort of 17th 18th century mathematics
and then suddenly something comes out of
this as you're exploring the
consequences which is linking to sort of
20th and 21st century mathematics and
very abstract mathematics so things like
elliptic curves and and you know number
Theory which you know as a physicist you
would never have actually thought that
you were going to go anywhere near there
but somehow you realize you discover
that it actually has it surprised you
when it's happened to you oh absolutely
absolutely I mean really surprised right
absolutely absolutely so so you know you
you you you know you're trying to sort
of you know describe some physical
phenomena you've turned it into some
equations you're manipulating these
equations and then you come up with
something which you know is a question
in number Theory it's a question of you
know how many prime numbers at a certain
level or something like that and you
know well how could that have been and
that was relevant to the original
question or counting the number of
Curves on a riemanned surface or
something like that counting the number
of Curves on a two-dimensional donut
surface or something you know how could
that be relevant to what you were trying
to do before but that's where it's going
towards you so it's it's really
completely entwined and really fun by
the way so if you've got kids in the
room please do physics it's fun
how do you see this relationship yeah so
I think I think there is there is an
understandable puzzlement about the idea
that there could be abstract objects so
things that an abstract by abstract we
mean or at least so for instance the
philosopher Fraga who defined this term
meant things that don't exist in space
or time and that have no cause or powers
and those are what numbers are supposed
to be on sets or whatever the
mathematical entities we believe in are
you can understand why people have a
certain degree of puzzlement about that
because of course those aren't things
that we see and they aren't things that
we interact with in any sort of causal
way so how can we know about them all
why do we why do we think about them uh
but of course the answer to that I think
is that if you come at it from a
thoroughly empirical empiricist
perspective where you think
understanding you know knowledge comes
through experience you can see for parts
of the reasons that we've already seen
that we believe in things because they
form part of what explains what we
observe and indeed mathematics does fall
part of what explains what we observe I
mean just to take one example from
outside of of physics if you think the
fact that a certain number 17 I think is
prime explains certain facts about the
periodicity about of cicadas I think so
they said certain animals which behave
in certain ways because certain numbers
of prime and that's why either way it's
not surprising that they do so there are
strange cases where mathematical truths
form an explanatory uh aspect of what we
observe and that's the reason that we
have for believing in them so I don't
think the mere fact that mathematical
objects are not located and they don't
have causal effects on us it shows that
we can't have any knowledge of them I
think we can if we're thoroughly
empiricist about it so I think we should
be to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas